yeah hello and welcome to this video
thing I am nastradamus who is that hardy
aight who are interesting a 3 is the
front line and now we place that can go
wait if i do this is going you for right
yeah this is not that that much little
problem is going before my god what
whatever exactly oh yeah ah complete
wackiness before jeez ok I'm not taking
that i am not taking that i'm just going
to prepare g5 and the center and
whatever you can do whatever you want
there with this stuff a 3 and so on I
just want to play in the center
that's kind of unclear what all this
from the cheese cam besides weakening
widescreen side and he cannot even play
t3 now and if I do this what are you
doing then d 5 or maybe I may be desired
I'm sure that this was even a great idea
yes default doesn't really do much but
okay I should be okay anyway so if i go
Bishop a six now he has to play d 3 by
the clay let's do it and see if i can
open this up quickly I mean that's an
extremely artificial wide set up so that
cf6 takes Bishop takes Bishop t2 and ce4
something like that let's let's try that
actually I can prove this to now be 50
to 80 °c for maybe then Catholic will
fail maybe it plays Queen to d2 there
quickly to problem e 6 is somewhat
hanging
yeah very likely Queenie too yeah now i
don't i don't like to play play Queen d7
or something like that I would rather
play something aggressive if possible
but I probably have to play that move
now still looks pretty good f night at
five now 494 they cannot take your
Bishop takes wins the exchange
headwinds Uruk right why doesn't that
you in a Roku weird flight hey guys oh
yeah I understand here I've got the
chest base file open with my games since
why it gave her over there okay so and
that was a really weird obeying place at
San put the engine on you had to a
three-year does this stuff that's even a
book published on that move which is
kind of crazy so yeah 93 years what he
actually can do here is Bishop c4 and
it's kind of interesting that is the
same setup that I'm employing with with
black against once you form I mean that
cannot be completely terrible of course
I mean a three and remove that probably
doesn't give much but you also should
not be in any trouble yeah before I just
type B 6 and I know the resulting
position just locally yet what wiped it
down when the Queen side this is a 63
and yeah now and I wanted to do
something quickly because I'm better
developed and this looks logical 92 now
given by the engine is probably stronger
and now I'm opening things out yeah here
I was thinking if I can do something
more aggressive but Queen d7 is also the
engines move council online at five and
now we just have to play something else
oh I have to take the door but i think
it was clear that 95 blundered the game
something else and probably a bit better
as the engine says okay thanks for
watching